>>> SOMETIMES GETTING A GOOD
NIGHT'S REST
EYES.
WHEN THE WORK DAY YOU HAD
THREATENS TO RUIN THE NIGHT'S
SLEEP YOU WANT, YOU NEED
SOMETHING THAT WORKS.
THERE'S ONLY ONE
OVER-THE-COUNTER SLEEP AID THAT
ANSWERS THE QUESTION, HOW DO YOU
SLEEP AT NIGHT?
IT'S HUCK-A-P.M.
THE ONLY SLEEP MEDICATION STRONG
ENOUGH FOR SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS.
>> PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS ASKING ME,
HOW DO YOU SLEEP AT NIGHT?
IN FACT, THEY SCREAM IT AT ME
ALL DAY LONG.
>> LOOK, THE CARAVAN IS HEADING
STRAIGHT FOR US!
AND IT'S FILLED WITH MS-13s!
>> THAT'S WHY WHEN I'M READY FOR
BED, I ALWAYS REACH FOR MY
SECRET WEAPON.
JUST ONE LITTLE PILL IS ENOUGH
TO EASE ME INTO THE GENTLEST
OF --
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HUCK A-A P.M. CONTAINS
ALL-NATURAL HORSE TRANQUILIZERS
IN COMBINATION WITH WHAT MICHAEL
JACKSON'S DOCTOR CALLED ONE AND
DONE.
NO MATTER WHAT TOMORROW'S
WORKLOAD BRINGS, I KNOW IT WON'T
KEEP ME UP AT NIGHT.
CNN IS ISIS SPELLED BACKWARDS.
SOUND GOOD TO ME, SIR.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THIS IS THE ONLY SLEEP AID I'LL
REACH FOR.
ALL RIGHT, BIRTHRIGHT
CITIZENSHIP IS OVER.
IT'S THE DEMOCRATS' FAULT.
I WANT YOU TO REMEMBER THAT.
SO LET'S WRAP UP THEM BABIES AND
GEM ATHLETE OUT OF HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WOW, THAT WAS EXHAUSTING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HUCK-A-P.M., HOW DO YOU SLEEP
AT NIGHT?
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ LAUGHTER ]